few weeks ago I was at a conference in
Russia and like all Russian conferences
there was banquet and at the banquet
they produced some special bottles of
vodka so-called czars vodka saskia vodka
I didn't think this was anything special
but the chemists were giggling and then
they explained to me that saskia vodka
is what Russians call the mixture of HCl
and nitric acid that we call aqua Riga
the mixture that dissolves gold so I got
really excited and wanted a bottle of
this vodka but being Russia all the
bottles were empty so I got an empty
bottle which I brought back home well it
wasn't quite empty there was a small
amount of vodka in the bottom and once I
got it home I thought it would be really
fun to make some aqua regia in the
bottle of sasuke vodka and of course who
should make the aqua region the answer
was obvious
Niel our technician so I gave him the
bottle and possibly he tested the little
bit of vodka that was left
yes tested it yeah and then he is now
done the experiment of course we have
already shown you gold dissolving in
aqua regia I wanted to see it in the
vodka bottle the key technical question
is how do you hang a piece of gold into
a bottle without whatever it's suspended
on dissolving the actual reader as well
now it should be quite obvious to you
that aqua reader doesn't dissolve glass
because otherwise the bottle would go
away so Neal had the very bright idea
that we would hang the gold from a very
thin fiber of glass and then everything
should be okay so let's see what's
happened so aqua regia is quite a
complicated mixed
in which the nitrogen part of the nitric
acid in fact becomes positively charged
with chloride ions from the hydrochloric
acid being the negative part so you have
a pair of ions of course nitric acid is
hno3 so it contains both nitrogen and
oxygen so the cation the positively
charged iron contains both nitrogen and
oxygen and in the solution this nitrogen
iron oxidizes the gold and removes
electrons from the gold and it reacts
with the chloride and it dissolves and
people for hundreds of years have been
really amazed that you can dissolve gold
and I'm still amazed because it just
seems something that shouldn't happen
the other thing is that as the aqua
regia reacts the whole color of the
solution goes darker as well part of
this is due to the gold dissolving as
you can see we don't have very much gold
because although we work in a high-class
university we still can't throw away
large lumps of gold and so much of the
color actually comes from the nitrogen
species than the solution and like many
other mixtures it takes time to mature
if we had been doing the experiment
really properly we would have left the
aqua regia sitting in the bottle for
some hours just to see how the color
changed then we would have emptied it
out washed everything made a new mixture
and done it with gold to see if there
was any difference but although neal is
a wonderful technician his patience has
definite limits i think it's a nice
demonstration of aqua regia and you've
learnt a little russian now when you see
aqua regia you can say Sasuke vodka
so I shall wash the bottle out or
edgeless kneel to wash it out and then
it will join the other vodka bottles in
the display in my office so that people
can see the historic experiments that
have been done for periodic videos so
you should watch our other vodka videos
too